[Música]
[Aplausos]
martes 3 de mayo de 2016
cuál
ven
dos simples palabras que estaban por
cambiar mi vida en sí yo ha usado
para mi esposo
dos palabras que no puede oír sin antes
entrar en pánico
mientras me bañaba encontré una bolita
en mi seno izquierdo que sabía no tenía
por qué estar ahí
después de tanto reflexionar lo y salir
de la regadera era tiempo de pedir una
segunda opinión
ya saben a quién y como lo llamen
llegamos a la misma conclusión no tenía
por qué estar ahí
tomé en ese momento mi celular para
llamarle a víctor mi ginecólogo y si
dije ginecólogo porque no es posible que
a pesar de que estamos en pleno siglo 21
aún causa sentimientos de vergüenza de
miedo de pena esto tiene que acabar
estamos en pleno siglo 21
víctor acordó en esperarme pues estaba
por terminar su última consulta del día
al llegar realizó una palpación un
sonograma hijo es un fibroma porque
acabas de dejar de amamantar recomendó
un tratamiento de algún par de días un
fonograma más especializado en el cual
se recomendaba otro estudio aún más
especializado
los resultados de ese último estudio
llegaron el día de mi boda por increíble
que parezca
y la bolita que encontré con mis manos
resultó que no era algo tan bueno
desde ese mayo del 2016 y parte del 2017
me tocó luchar contra lo que más miedo
me daría en la vida y eso que soy madre
mía en el travieso de sus terribles dos
años
luche contra el cáncer de mama
y lo vencí
días antes de comenzar mi tratamiento
donde mi cabello y el día 0 llegó
o lo que yo le llamo más bien el intento
de convertirme en un mutante
serían 7 quimioterapias algunas antes y
otras después de la cirugía 33
radiaciones algunas vacunas y con todo
esto llegó
una serie de malestares de cambios de
humor de ataques de pánico
y también preguntas que iban desde la
más irónica hasta las más existenciales
como quien iba a dar de comer a los
perros y animales garras plantas quién
le iba a decir a juan que dejara de
roncar
estaré aquí para ver crecer a demián
para verlos graduarse
se caerá mi cabello
me voy a morir
tendré mis dos senos
muchas preguntas ahorita resultan
irrelevantes otras quizás ya no quiero
saber la respuesta
te puedo contar un millón de anécdotas
que me sucedieron en este año y medio
como alguien sin más ni más me dijo que
me iba a morir como gente tan estúpida y
limitada de neuronas creyó que todo esto
era un juego
caramba tenía cáncer
no es una enfermedad o creo yo que con
ninguna enfermedad se juega
para autoexplorarse no necesitas nada
nada
extraordinario
un espejo
tus manos puede ser en la regadera como
fue mi caso
y tocarla
sabían que los hombres también les puede
suceder
y saben muchísima menor escala que a
nosotras las mujeres pero sucede
te puedo manejar cifras
enorme
como que en el 2017 se detectaron
alrededor de un millón de casos y
alrededor del 45% de los pacientes o los
pacientes fallecieron que de cada
100.000 casos 35 eran hombres pero estoy
segura que ella se te olvidan porque son
números enormes te lo pueden simplificar
de una manera más fácil y aquí me ayudan
por favor todos poniéndose en pie o
quienes pueden ponerse de pie me ayudan
poniéndose de pie por favor
vamos a cerrar
un segundo los ojos
y vamos a imaginar
que todos aquí somos pacientes de cáncer
de mama
de aquí
de aquí para acá vamos a aceptarnos
todos por favor
también atrás
lamento informarles que fallecieron a
causa del cáncer de mama gracias pueden
sentarse
obtuve el cáncer de mama no es solo en
octubre cuando usamos este monitor rosa
tan mono o hacer retos en las redes
sociales quizás sin sentido como nómina
20 que pongan su foto saca la lengua con
la imagen de tu perrito no sé lo que más
les guste
el cáncer de mama es todos los días no
solo en octubre
lo único que tengo yo es común con
octubre
es que de la fecha que estaba por
terminar mi tratamiento
tenemos que liberarnos de la idea de que
es una enfermedad de que hablamos con la
abuelita de que hablamos con el doctor
de que hablamos entre amigas es un tema
que nos incumbe a todos
en el trayecto
recobre
mi espiritualidad
y mi gratitud con la vida
con las cosas tan simples común
el beso de buenos días de mi esposo la
voz que me grita desde la cuna mamá
en las noches que había que pasar en el
hospital y junto a mí estaba mi mamá
cuando quizá ella estaba más asustada
que yo
en las llamadas de mi mejor amiga
cada equipo terapia
que necesitaba
en las lágrimas que vi derramar aparte
de las mías
a la persona que siempre creí más fuerte
que yo
mi hermana
pero ella también aprendió
que llorar no significa que seas débil
sino porque te has cansado de ser fuerte
te puedo contar de las personas
asombrosas que conociendo el camino
y de cómo a mí
me tocó quizá mojar a alguien que
también estaba muerto de miedo
por último te voy a pedir que cierres
una vez más tus ojos
e imagines por mí
que hubiera pasado
si no encuentro con mis manos
esa bolita
el final no me lo digas
yo me quedo con la imagen de que le
encontré
y lo ves
gracias
[Aplausos]